[Music]
[Music]
we're coming to the end of the first
quarter with the rhinos in the red zone
for the first time
gotta say bill i like watching these
rhinos ransom takes the snap
drops back with good protection and
that's a completed pass to a very
wide-open hingle mccrinkleberry the
rookie out of penn state
nice graph i'm buying the kringleberry
you think he's happy oh boy he is loving
it down there
oh we got something of a shooting
gallery oh yeah look at that boy that is
something and
oh oh wait we got a flag though you got
that for excessive celebration yeah
well see and i'm not sure about that
called i don't know bill that was three
pumps and the rule book says you cannot
have more than two
oh my gosh but look at the kid he's
pleading his case with the wrath
pleading his case
yeah clearly three pops coast johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the rhinos again
threatening to score
can the cougars hold them big play
coming here bill ransom takes the snap
drops back
he floats one into the end zone and
mcringleberry pulls it down oh he's got
it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie
he has got to be feeling great about
himself nice i'll tell you
man he's oh oh see now there's two pumps
yeah he's really testing the boundaries
and he's clearly gotten the refs
attention here a third pump will draw a
flag no matter what
see oh he just did it again what did now
what is that the second time now you
have to flag him on it yeah he had to
you know bill it's just frustrating
seeing young players without the ability
to restrain themselves oh it really is
it's hard i mean the ref's gonna get you
every time yeah yeah absolutely uh see
now the ref agrees that's three pumps
right there
[Applause]
and the quarterback ransom under center
last five minutes of the game
rhinos are marching here again hard to
stop this team from scoring bill they
have so many weapons
ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
past the mcringleberry ooh he's at the
10. he's at the five
and touchdown rhino oh my great block by
hardunka chut and that's gonna be tough
for the cougars to come back from boy
what a career day from hingle
mccrinkleberry the rookie out of penn
state
oh he was just amazingly fired up here
today john you gotta love the way this
guy plays and he
oh oh see now there's one pump oh
well i cannot believe this kid you got
to put your team first in situations
like this and the cringleberry's just
not doing it no there's two
jeff now if he pumps a third time he
will draw his third penalty for today
everybody here waiting with betty breath
he didn't oh did he yes he did it oh
that's just couldn't help himself
amazing i mean
come on in professional football it's
really changed yeah that's what it is
you can argue all you want but
flag well it's been thrown that's right
if it's three pumps the ref's not going
to take it away now
duration and intensity doesn't make any
difference jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed
he did do the three pumps all right no
question there is the first one yeah
right agreed
and then coming up is the second one
okay yes very clear it's the third we'll
see it it's coming up
here oh yeah you're right there's
absolutely three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh
clearly unintentional i am here with
osman says buckshank the rookie out of
stanford university
who is undoubtedly the mvp of today's
game
with an interception that he runs back
for a touchdown in the last 30 seconds
of the contest
osmotes can you walk us through what
happened on that last play it was
amazing yeah we knew we had to go out
there
give a hundred percent we executed it
just went our way today
and was the quarterback giving you any
clues uh today oz uh
it looked like you knew that ball was
gonna be there what was happening knew
we wanted to
have some fun you know execute play one
quarter at a time give a hundred percent
i'm sorry okay okay you know let's just
let's talk about last week's game
uh uh you guys lost a heartbreaker give
me your state of mind
then versus now i wanted to do
play-by-play give it a hundred percent
wise execute okay yo i'm going to ask
you something completely different
that's not about football look at me oz
just look at me saying i'm going to ask
you a question
right here got it boy so you and your
wife recently had
right here stay with me you and your
wife recently had twins okay how does it
feel to be a new dad
you know we wanted to stay as a team
execute give a hundred percent
play by play okay you know what i'm
gonna just i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do a little test right now uh
hey oz how did you get to the game today
they're a good team great team
100 yep
and what you had for dinner last night
100 of 100 yeah you're dead of course
100
or whatever 100 was you know what
can you just do me a favor and tell me
one specific thing like just one
actual original observation that you had
about today's game the game that you won
almost single-handedly do you think that
you could do that oz
oh 100 oh god damn it okay we are now
going live to a breaking press
conference where seattle cornerback
richard sherman has something to say
first off i would like to say thank you
to everybody who
came out tonight uh appreciate you
getting up and coming here
at this late hour um there's some things
that need to be said
some issues i'd like to talk about that
are non-football related
and without any further ado i'm just
gonna get to it
how you gonna tell me the lego movie is
not gonna get nominated for one
of the best animated films of the year
inconceivable okay
huge box office success
critical consensus everybody gave it an
a i mean hey
this is the one movie if they could have
done it they would have given this
106 on rotten tomatoes
okay nobody didn't like the lego movie i
don't care if you're two or 92.
so you're telling me that this movie is
not one of the five
best animated films of the year
but how you gonna nominate selma for
best film and ava duvernay not gonna get
a director nomination
like i don't understand exactly how that
works i'm not a member of the academy
but it seems like things are a little
backwards there wouldn't you agree
marshawn
hibiscus engraving furthermore how y'all
gonna give bennett miller
a best director nomination but then
you're not gonna nominate the film fox
catcher
okay which he directed which was good he
was masterful in his job
it's just i don't you know what's going
on like it's
like what's the logic there you don't
mean to be that good of a job
then how come the film is not nominated
for academy award
biscuits and gravy
you get to nominate 10 films every year
but this year you decide you're only
going to nominate eight films
if you got the space to do it and you
all like fox catcher so much that you're
gonna give the director
a director nomination then why would you
not nominate the film
same goes for ava duvernay you already
made selma
a film that you want to win the award
but then you're not going to let her
get her due or her accolades
it's just something seems off here
something seems
off
[Music]
hibiscus from bravery
thank you so much i'm sorry just that we
needed to get that off of my chest
all right and now marshawn has something
very important that he needs to say
that's very close to his heart marshawn
biscuits and gravy no no no something
really real that he want to say
with four sentences
there was a biscuit with some gravy no
no go on marshall
speak your mind marshawn lynch
[Music]
i just think that the producers of enter
the woods did they sell as a disservice
by not including the narrator from the
original
musical theater production boom
as in legion of
but that's on you that's on y'all
biscuits and gravy
we're not taking any questions thank you
very much go hawks
say he could have been the greatest
player on his team
or perhaps the greatest player of his
generation
perhaps he could have been the greatest
player of all time
[Music]
if only he didn't run in slow motion
[Applause]
that's right y'all cause you know what
we only get
one chance let's leave it all on the
field today
we gonna give them something they can
remember yeah
yeah let's do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to handle our business
is
[Music]
this is our moment we can't let nobody
take this away from us
we got to do this
[Applause]
you know i got your backyard i know
y'all got mine
we're taking this all the way to the
super bowl y'all
this is our destiny
let's keep doing
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
can nobody stop us
we can do anything we set our minds to
[Music]
uh
play this game like at the last game of
your life
[Music]
oh